Allison Holker x' post baby body is  incredible  the Dancing with the Stars Pro took to  Instagram Wednesday showing off her  progress just three months after giving  birth  check out Allison's amazing pregnancies  snapback the 28 year old sported a  matching crop top and gym leggings  riding in the caption quote post baby  body working hard every day to feel like  my 100 again keep pushing keep striving  keep improving all day every day allison  welcomed her second child a baby boy  named Maddox back in March the newborn  is her first child with husband Stephen  twitch boss the mom of two has been  keeping her followers up to date on her  fitness routine frequently sharing  photos from the gym here's Alison  getting in a sweat session two months  post baby and her rock-hard abs and  toned arms are unreal now there's some  fits per a shin for you